well certainly the government wanted you
to believe that it was the patriotic
thing to do to to buy some war bonds and
they certainly promoted them very
heavily and if you couldn't go out and
fight then it was suggested that
whatever spare money wealth you might
have then that would be wise to invest
that to help the war effort by putting
that money in the war box nevertheless
they offered five percent interest
recourse by today's sand and sounds very
generous even they're not bad was that
because they fear that perhaps being
patriotic was important there that's
right i mean five percent was a really
good rate of return at the time and it
was considerably more than other
government securities and the other
important thing really about the war
bonds and what made them very attractive
was that they were also considered very
secure so for the hesitant investor the
investor wanted security the warbands
seemed very attractive to them he was
buying them hugging 20,000 still they
have well it's interesting I mean this
is a popular perception that the war
bond holders were generally sort of
wealthy middle-class types but actually
I'm doing some research with the Bank of
England at moments and what we're
beginning to discover from their records
of those people who invested is that
they came from quite a broad variety of
different backgrounds so there are a
good number of shopkeepers for example
people in small manufacturing trades
people in professional occupations
another striking thing actually is a
number of women who are investing in war
bonds and particularly single women so
widows and spinsters what was the sort
of lowest chunk of war bond you could
buy the lowest amount well we know now
actually that around the third of those
who still hold war bonds have bombs
valued at less than 100 pounds so it did
go down to two relatively low levels and
somewhere in the region of eighty
percent own bombs worth less than a
thousand pounds so this was really
actually smaller than alveolar time 11
the the annual salary was what it was
good well you're right i mean at that
time it was worth considerably more but
but still this was something that was
within the reach of I guess groups that
we might describe this as a lower middle
class and what happened because of
course we're talking over a century ago
now so as they've just been passed down
generations is that how it works that's
often what happens if it could of course
sell their war bonds but it's clear that
actually many would just passed on so as
people died they you know mention these
in their will
pass them on to their relatives and I
was talking to a friend the other day
and she was saying how in her family
there are still some of these war bonds
a small amount but nevertheless
something that's been handed down in
that way but basically as I understand
it what the government has done is you
know it's good accounting practice that
they were paying too much interest yeah
literally sure so the government has
looked at this and you know that they're
still paying a fairly hefty rate of
interest at the current time when
interest rates are so low so in spite of
the costs of contacting all those
bondholders and and you know giving them
their money back it's still worth their
while to do this and borrow at a lower
rate